a
[Música]
ah
venezuela es la cuarta crisis
alimentaria más grave del mundo según la
ong oxfam que dice que 9.3 millones de
venezolanos tiene un nivel de hambre
entre moderado y agudo 9.3 millones de
una población de casi 30 esta ong que
sólo tiene cifras de 2019 antes de la
pandemia dice que entre 50 y 80 por
ciento de los venezolanos saltan comida
o reducen porciones y que otras familias
han tenido que vender bienes personales
para costear alimentos incluso usar a
sus hijos para pedir ayuda hoy diferente
a lo que ocurría años atrás cuando
comenzó la crisis económica en este país
los anaqueles de los supermercados están
llenos de productos pero qué pasa los
precios están dolarizados y pocos pueden
pagarlos con un sueldo mínimo que no
llega a tres dólares en caracas en el
oeste por ejemplo es común ver a gente
hurgando en la basura por algo de comer
también esto ocurre en la provincia
mucho más golpeada hacia la capital al
no tener cifras de 2020 el informe de
oxfam no logra determinar si hubo un
aumento o disminución del hambre
respecto al año 2019
en haití la mitad de los 11 millones de
habitantes padece de inseguridad
alimentaria grave según alertó de la
organización de las naciones unidas para
la alimentación y la agricultura un
informe de oxfam ubica al país caribeño
entre las zonas más críticas que sufren
hambre extrema en el mundo sólo por
debajo de países como siria sudán del
sur y yemen y revela que el número de
afectados ha aumentado en un 11% desde
2019 la situación que ya era compleja
debido a diversos factores como la
inestabilidad política los fenómenos
naturales y la violencia de pandillas
armadas se ha agudizado aún más por la
pandemia de kobe 19 las mujeres y los
niños son quienes más se han visto
impactados de acuerdo con unicef que
describió el panorama como la peor
crisis humanitaria en los últimos años
en el país que ya es el más pobre de
américa expertos aseguran que debido al
contexto actual haitiano las
expectativas son pésimas no sólo para lo
que queda de 2021 sino para el siguiente
año
en bolivia el 20% de la población es
decir 2.4 millones de habitantes están
alimentados de manera insuficiente según
el mapa del hambre del programa mundial
de alimentos esta misma herramienta
ubica al país entre los 15 focos de
riesgo a nivel mundial en cuanto al
deterioro de la seguridad alimentaria
según datos oficiales la desnutrición
aguda en bolivia está por debajo del 5%
pero con una tendencia creciente estos
datos sin embargo no contemplan el
impacto que pudo haber tenido la
pandemia en la seguridad alimentaria de
los bolivianos los organismos
internacionales sin embargo destacan el
avance que hubo en bolivia en
comparación a otros países que están en
la misma situación indicando que en la
década comprendida entre el 2010 y el
2020 bolivia pudo bajar del 30 al 20 por
ciento la población que está alimentada
de manera insuficiente atribuyen esta
situación de riesgo a los desastres
naturales que año tras año dejan sin
alimento a muchas comunidades indígenas
de bolivia
[Música]